there was like an interview or something
and i think it was you
where uh it came up how like how johnny
knoxville
and the jackass guys like came together
to like step in and do an intervention
on me
which ultimately saved my life man you
know like i've been clean and clean and
sober ever since
and uh there was something it was a
really like like a touching
like you know really made me like
emotional to hear
i think it was you saying man if only we
could have done that for odb
you know like yeah and uh
it's just not always it's not always
that easy man it's uh
you know and i mean you you speak from
experience so
you know how hard that is
and then in the sense that
when dirty got locked up
isolated from the people he loved um
i not a lot of members went to go visit
old dirty
i personally went there once with rizzo
to go visit dirty i didn't
like what i had saw um so dirty
coming home from that
you know a lot of love and care from his
family his mom was there you know a lot
of support
um but i don't think it was enough to
keep dirty from being old dirty
yeah and like someone
i i can't speak to that addiction
but i understand
but in the same breath i feel like
people that [ __ ] is so [ __ ] selfish
in a sense that especially people that
need you here
i'm pretty sure his family would rather
have him here especially his kids and
his grandkids they would rather
have him here clean and sober and boring
then you know back to the essence i do i
don't think odb ever could have been
boring man
there's no [ __ ] way that he could
have been boring dude
i agree i agree i agree it's such a it's
such a beautiful soul
too because if you knew anything about
dirty dirty love people
love the [ __ ] out of people but he had
his vices you know
yeah uh yeah the world would be a better
place right now if he was still here i
tell you that much man
yeah dude how did you meet dirty um
through rizza through reza and it was
just this
this loud the thing about dirty that
stood out to me was
impeccably dressed all the time and
just loud and always had a 40 ounce in
his hand you know
and his cadence was always different he
never in my opinion
said his verses the same way twice
ever and he proved it on his album
because he did the same verse on three
different records
on that album the same verse i'll grab
the mic and i damager
that verse he did it three times on that
album not the refurbished one
get the original copy because they took
it they took that song off of there
and added um a song off the jerky boy
soundtrack called dirty dancing
but he did it three times the same
verse as there is a vouch for me for
this and said it different
all three times to the point where
people didn't even notice it you
probably wouldn't have noticed if i
didn't tell you
yeah it's definitely still on there
twice
guess what i have the number 30 ranked
hot sauce on
all of amazon it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude